[Music]
from the acclaimed director of the Lord
of the Rings trilogy who really should
have moved on by now and the
money-grubbing studio who's continuing
the awful trend of splitting one Shore
book into multiple unnecessary movies
comes the first installment of the
trilogy that should really only have one
installment
an unexpected journey will get the days
of good standalone movies and settle in
for a three hour long prologue for a
sequel that looks far more interesting
but also just as unnecessary shot on
location in some of New Zealand's most
beautiful green screen studios and
filmed in such high definition
it made audiences want to hurl returned
to middle-earth and stay there way too
long for a story that takes over 40
minutes to even get started and watch as
a movie tries its damnedest to trick you
into thinking it's the Lord of the Rings
but isn't featuring another fellowship
another spooky mountain another Eagle
rescue the rain New Zealand Gollum and
these Lord of the Rings characters that
weren't even in the book but instead of
saving the entire world from evil this
time they're saving one city from smog
small with smog smog asleep oh I smile
whatever meet 13 interchangeable dwarves
Thorin borin durin Dora bra bra war
nosy-ass skip next
oh wow look Gandalf together they'll
team up with a random unprepared Hobbit
who steals from the mentally handicapped
for yet another middle-earth adventure
full of even more walking
[Music]
and singing
or get the extended edition to see even
more singing and wandering around
[Music]
sorry dozed off for a second there man
I can't believe there's gonna be two
more of these prepare for their movie
trilogy adapted from a 300 page book
that'll ultimately be just as long as
the last religion which was adapted from
three four hundred page books and
experience a movie that has a three hour
runtime but so little story you can
basically sum it up like this
so instead of return of the Kings eight
different endings watch a movie that
doesn't even have one but you won't even
mind since it means you can finally go
home and watch Game of Thrones I
survived the last is behind us you said
it buddy
starring dildo Dagon's your parents
favorite band birds face mama toon honey
Boo Boo's hobos nod Viggo Mortensen
those rock people from he-man precious
based on the novel push by Sapphire god
of war Galaga Mel and straight
Dumbledore The Hobbit I totally expected
letdown look I know there's a dragon
there and everything but couldn't the
Eagles have dropped them off a little
bit closer to the mountain lazy Birds
for more awesome stuff be sure to click
our process subscribe button screw you
guys I'm going home that really rustled
my jimmies donkey boner I'm looking at
you through the window such honest mini
trailer
Wow